[Music]
guys guys they did it again Netflix man
they did they they broke the Internet
that's Super Bowl 1 the Cloverfield
paradox came out and now they're at it
again welcome by the way to the reject
nation how's it going guys good to be
back it's John Humphrey here hope y'all
are having a nice holiday season but
Netflix here just dropped a new trailer
for a black mirror movie which you can
now stream on Netflix so this is new
this is exciting I don't know anything
about this but apparently this is a
black mirror feature-length film which
is if you've seen any black mirror
episodes I mean they could all basically
be feature-length films if you do the
pattern but we'll see we'll see also
just want to give a quick shout out to
everybody who's joining us on patreon
lately thank you guys so much you've
helped to make it a really happy holiday
as well it's just a great year overall
really excited about the growth going on
over there and if y'all are interested
we got a ton of fun and exclusive
content including weekly Q&A si do music
video coverage now we also full-length
TV show reactions to show such as my
hero academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood attack on Titan Gotham
Riverdale and supernatural we have a lot
of fun over there would love it if you
would come join us become a patron eject
today and speaking of which shouts out
to a patron of the day at the end of
this video for Daniel Gallagher but for
right now let's let's get our souls
messed up it's like what black mirrors
best dad here we go
if it dreams wait days things love that
black mere grit
oh damn oh man
[Music]
[Music]
black mirror vents
unless you seen a bigger picture
[Music]
yeah that's a good cut
ah damn nose that was a quick old
trailer right there all right I mean not
bad that definitely got me intrigued I
will probably go watch this quite soon
but um man I'm interested in that I mean
the thing is beyond the basic setup I'm
not really getting a ton from this
trailer other than the aesthetic and hey
I mean I got to give it to Black Mirror
they always have a very strong visual
sense that was every strong sense for
writing in character I mean even in the
lesser episodes that I haven't seen the
entire series just yet but even in the
lesser episodes I mean there's always
something interesting happening at the
core and this seems like new territory
for them in a way it's a feature-length
film from what I understand you know
it's solid 90 minutes
I wonder how their style is going to
suit that I mean honestly like I said in
the intro their episodes are so movie
like anyway that I don't think this
would have a hard time working out and
just in general I mean the style overall
looks really cool this story looks
intriguing from what I gather this guy's
trying to adapt this book into a video
game and some weird [ __ ] is gonna happen
in pursuit of doing that and I wonder to
what these significance of the title
here is gonna be I mean I know they said
it's this is a book that they're
adapting and the author went crazy and
like decapitated his wife or something
like that but the Bandersnatch you know
is like a mythical creature if I'm not
mistaken and is a word you know an
illusion a lot of people have made over
time and various sci-fi and horror
properties and stuff like that so I
wonder how much that lore is gonna
figure into this because I always find
things like that kind of fascinating and
fun and you know this looks like the
kind of story that I kind of tend to
gravitate toward in my frot sci-fi
something that probably starts a bit
grounded and then deteriorates over time
probably gets a bit surreal as it goes
and I mean fian Whitehead who I
I was trying this whole trailer in a
place where I recognize him from and
he's the lead I gave if Dunkirk has a
lead it's this guy
and I really liked his performance in
that movie so I'm excited to see him
lead something a bit more contemporary I
mean this is still a period piece since
the 80s but it's more recent you know
I'm excited to see what he brings to
this as well as will Poulter too I mean
you know he was almost penny wise man so
that got me intrigued just about what
his chops are outside of the one comedy
I got to see him in so it's cool to see
him in this trailer yeah I mean just I
wonder how crazy this is gonna go at the
beginning he's talking about like oh you
need some mind alteration when you're
getting into something conceptual like
this you know and I'm sure there's gonna
be a lot of metaphor in here I'm sure
that this is going to be an allegory of
some kind and even though he throws away
those pills at the top of this trailer I
gotta imagine that he will get suckered
in at some point and I mean there are
just so many crazy images in here you
know he's got his hand going inside of
this mirror you've got these like weird
creature hands and stuff and dilating
eyes and chemicals being dropped onto
sweets and stuff
yeah I mean I really don't get much of a
sense for where this is going to take us
in an allegorical fashion other than you
know in a story of obsession and mind
alteration of some sort but I'm excited
to check it out they definitely have
that tone that makes you need to take a
shower afterwards and sometimes that's a
place I like to go but I don't know what
do you guys think have you seen the
movie did you dig it please keep the
spoilers out of the comments if you can
I know that's a futile gesture to make
but if you can help yourself it would be
nice just to hear if a what's y'all are
expecting based on this trailer and be
if you've seen it if you liked it if you
think it's worth checking out or if this
is just a cool trailer and before we
wrap up this video
Daniel Gallacher how is it going man I
hope you're doing well Daniel's all the
way out in Scotland not very far from
where the black mirrors get made and
Daniel I mean the last I heard from you
I mean you're a cinephile you watch a
lot of flicks and stuff but you're also
completing your training to be a
pharmacist so I hope that you could
probably recommend us the proper
mind-altering substances to really help
us enjoy this movie to the fullest and
hey I mean we've both been branching out
into some other creative territories and
stuff so I imagine that at some point
we'll get
to adapt a videogame and at which point
you know seems like drugs are gonna be a
significant part of that process so I
want you to get that prescription pad
out man's start filling us up with
pharmaceuticals because that's what good
friends do but in all seriousness man I
hope you do it well hope you're having a
good winter season out there in Scotland
never been and I've always wanted to go
it's fine we have a few patronage acts
out in Scotland so greetings out there
are you gonna check this out you you you
I'd be curious to hear your thoughts and
yes to the rest of you thank you very
much for tuning in thanks for watching
and just thanks for being around all
year long those of you who have followed
this channel any length of time and yeah
that's it for now you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification about to get updated every
time a review or a video is out also
check us out in the star nest app as
well as on patreon would love to have
you become a patron inject today if you
love this channel of course if not go
about your merry way and until next time
party people Cheers
[Music]